We're on Test 5, Section
9, on page 679.
Let's do some problems.
Problem number 1.
If 6 cars out of 10 on an
assembly line are red, what is
the probability that a car
selected at random from the
assembly line will be red?
Well, 6 out of 10 are red.
So if I take a random one, I
have a 6 in 10 chance of
getting a red car.
If you look at the choices,
there is no 6/10, but you can
see that this can be reduced.
If you divide the top and the
bottom by 2, you get 3/5.
So this is really just an
exercise in reducing a
fraction to its lowest common
or simplified form, so the
answer is B.
Problem 2.
Let me draw that diagram.
So I have a triangle.
Let me try my best
to draw this.
There's an altitude that
comes down the center.
Let's put a 2.
And then what do they write?
They write this angle
right here is w.
This is x, y, z over here.
And they say, note: figure
not drawn to scale.
AB is equal to BC.
Oh, I didn't draw
the letters in.
So A, B, C, and then D.
So they say that AB
is equal to BC.
So immediately, a trigger should
go off in your head.
If two sides are equal, what
does it say about the base
angles or their corresponding
angles?
That means that those are
also going to be equal.
So if those two sides are equal,
then we also know that
these two angles are equal.
That should immediately be a
trigger in your head, that we
know that w is equal to z.
What's the next part
of the information?
And BD, this is BD,
bisects AC.
so bisects means it essentially
intersects it at
its midpoint.
So that also tells us that this
distance here from A to D
is the same as the distance
from D to C.
Which of the following
cannot be concluded?
That w is equal to x.
Actually, immediately, I
don't even know how I
can conclude that.
Let's look at the
other choices.
w is equal to z.
Well, w is equal to z can
definitely be concluded.
That's choice B.
So we know that choice
B is w is equal to z.
We know that this isn't it
because we concluded that
immediately.
Choice C is that x
is equal to y.
That actually can
be concluded.
How do we know that?
Well, since this bisects this
line and this is an isosceles
triangle, even though that's
not how I drew it.
This triangle is completely
symmetric.
Maybe I should draw a
little bit better.
How do I know it's completely
symmetric?
Because this side is equal to
this side, that is equal to
that, and this side is
equal to this side.
And of course, this side
is equal to that side.
And actually, we can also
conclude that this is a
90-degree angle, because if this
was anything other than a
90-degree angle, this wouldn't
be able to bisect at the base.
So choice C, we actually can
deduce that x is equal to y.
So that's not the answer.
Choice D is AD is equal to DC.
Well, they essentially
told us that one.
They said BD bisects AC, so
that's not our answer.
Choice E.
DB is perpendicular to AC.
And I just said the triangle
is completely symmetric.
And given that it's an isosceles
triangle, the only
way that BD can bisect this
bottom line is if it's
perpendicular.
So we can also rule out E.
So our answer really is A.
And really, there was no way
that we could figure out.
And a good way of thinking
about that is actually we
could make this point-- we could
make the length of this
line, this length BD,
arbitrarily high because they
gave us no information.
The triangle could
look like this.
It could look like that, or it
could look like this based on
the information they gave us.
So these angles could
change arbitrarily.
So we really don't know
what those angles are.
Next problem.
Problem 3.
Switch colors.
About to sneeze.
[SNEEZES]
Excuse me.
If 30% of m is 40, so 0.3
m, what is 15% of m?
What is 0.15 of m?
You could solve this.
Divide both sides by 0.3,
et cetera, et cetera.
But the important thing to
recognize is that 15%, or
0.15, is half of 0.13.
So if 15% is half of 0.3, or
30%, then 15% m is going to be
half of whatever 30% m is, so
it's going to be equal to 20.
Another thing you could have
done, if that's not completely
obvious, take this
top equation and
multiply it by 1/2.
Then you'll get 0.15m
is equal to 20.
And that's choice B.
Problem 4.
If n is any negative number, so
n is less than 0, which of
the following must
be positive?
So I can already tell you that
the only way you can take a
negative number and make it
positive is either if you
square it or if you multiply it
by another negative number.
So let's see.
Or if you subtract it, actually,
now that I look at
the choices.
So I could tell you an/2, that's
definitely going to be
a negative number.
B is definitely going to
be a negative number.
You're multiplying
by a positive.
C, you're just adding something
to it, so it still
could be negative, if that's
like negative 10
or something, right?
D, you're just subtracting from
it, so you're just going
to make it more negative.
E.
2 minus n.
This will definitely result
in a positive number.
Why?
Because let's say that you could
express n as the product
of a negative number.
Let's say n is equal to
minus p, where p is
some positive number.
You can represent any negative
number like that.
Then 2 minus n is the same
thing as 2 minus minus p,
which is the same thing
as 2 plus p.
And we said p is a
positive number.
So there we go.
So choice number 4
is definitely E.
And you could try it
out with a number.
Try it out with the number n
equals negative 10, and I
think it should work out.
Next problem.
Problem number 5.
The ratio 1.2:1 is equal to
which of the following ratios?
So they give us a bunch
of choices.
1.2:1, so it's a little
bit more than 1:1.
So we could look at 1:2.
No, that makes no sense, because
1 is smaller than 2.
12:1.
12 is 12 times 1,
not 1.2 times 1.
So you're just looking for a
ratio where the first number
is 1.2 times the
second number.
5:6, that's choice C.
That doesn't work, because
5 is less than 6.
Choice D.
6:5.
I think we hit it because 6 is
just a little bit more than 5.
And actually, if you wanted to
confirm that, why don't you
divide the top and
the bottom by 5?
So 5 goes into 6
how many times?
5 goes into 6 one time.
How many times does
5 go into 10?
It's 2.
5 goes into 6 1.2 times.
So the answer is 6:5.
Next problem.
Let's see if I have
time to do this.
Clear image.
Invert colors.
The legend of a certain
pictograph shows that this
thing is equal to 5
million new homes.
Approximately how many
new homes are
represented by the symbols?
So they drew that
3 and 1/2 times.
One, two, three, and then
they draw half a house.
That's half a house.
So these three are
going to be what?
This is 3 times 5, which is
equal to 15 million homes.
And then this is half a house.
That's what I tried to draw what
they drew in the diagram.
So half a house is what?
2.5 million houses.
It's just half of
the 5 million.
So it's 15 million plus 2.5.
It equals 17.5 million homes.
And that is choice D.
You might be tempted to say that
this represents half a
million homes, but remember,
this represents half of one of
these pictures.
And one of these pictures
represents 5 million homes.
So this is 2 and 1/2 million.
This is 2 and 1/2, not 0.5.
See you in the next video.